if you take responsibility and if you
take power and if you decide that the
one person who will be responsible for
your success is you
then
then then you can't be stopped there's
no way to stop you it's a it's you're on
your path
how does a screenwriter know that what
they've written is good
writers are often
misled in their own opinions of their
work they think the script is great when
it's really not
you need response from others and you
need to really listen
and not defend your work
now when you work in a mass medium and
you hear back from your fans or the show
is a success
then you know
and also as you get more and more
um polish in your craft you often know
you know when something's at least
competent you know when you you know
what what will work uh but the funny
thing is i often write scripts and
elaine is my uh the person i get notes
from and she often says this needs to be
better this needs to go deeper it's like
okay okay okay okay you know it's like
and that's good that's good because if
something doesn't have the depth or the
or the emotional line i need to know
that um and and frankly i wrote i wrote
one of this two-hour scripts of space
command
and we could absolutely shoot that draft
we absolutely could and it would more or
less work but it's not good enough so
we're going to scrap that entire draft
and start over again and i've actually
already done that and um and there's
characters we won't see that they're in
there and those characters work but
but the story as a whole isn't as good
as we can make it so we're going to go
back to the drawing board and that's
fine it's harder work but but eventually
i may publish you know the lost worlds
of space command and include that script
so people can see where it started
because it's an entertaining read but um
you know i i i need people in my life
who tell me if something's working or
not but at some point you draw the line
and you say okay we're
we're rocking and rolling we're not
gonna because you can you can endlessly
rewrite and you there's a point where
that's again where television is good if
they're shooting on monday you gotta at
some point you gotta say well
you know we're done
and and you know roll camera so you make
it as good as you can but then remember
that when you're the writer producer
director you the editing phase is the
final draft of the script so in fact
with space command we're editing um
finishing the first the second uh
episode with the visual visual effects
and everything and i realized there was
one scene that we needed to add so we
went back to the dailies we called our
actors we got some adr lines we put
together a scene that we never shot
and there it is you know and we'll have
a visual effects
shot of this
ship landing and planting a
part of a wrecked ship to use as an
explosive on the big alien ship and
it'll work it'll and no one will know
that we never shot that scene
so it's i love the so it's pressed to
depress the digitation
magic you know so it's fun
what about the reverse though what if
someone says this is horrible and i know
this is crap and someone else reads it
and they're not there's no agenda for
this person and they go actually this is
really good no no this is terrible this
is terrible if the check clears if the
check clears i mean if someone wants to
buy a script of yours it doesn't matter
what you think of it let them buy us you
know
it's but but on the other end let's say
you've written something and you think
it's crap right and they love it
or someone loves it and encourages you
the way you know if something if a note
is correct is that everyone is saying
the same thing
so in other words if five people read it
and they all say you know i just hated
when he killed the dog then you better
rewrite that you know but on the other
hand if one person loves it and you
don't like it
well they don't have to i mean it's like
then you can say well let me let me see
if there's something of value here but
don't don't be slavish to their opinion
they could easily be wrong
you know so if they love it that's fine
if they're going to buy it let them but
but don't i mean
you might re-read your script just with
a mind toward what maybe they're valuing
but don't don't trust it as holy writ
because they're probably wrong
and uh you know so but
at the end you know it's
you know but that's very rare that
someone says something that you think it
doesn't work and other people say it
does that's very rare that's what i was
wondering oh you know it's yeah usually
you think it's great and other people
think it sucks
yeah um
what are the reality check how
delusional yeah writers yeah but but but
there's always going to be people who
aren't on your wavelength so for
instance if i'm doing science fiction
and someone doesn't cue into what i'm
doing because they're not a science
fiction fan there's no right or wrong to
that it's just they are not
their head doesn't live where my head
lives you know and that's fine but
they're not going to be my audience
they're not i don't need to convince
them i don't need to rewrite you know
you have to be very careful of bad notes
notes that wreck your script and you
don't you that's where you really want
to make sure the people who are giving
you notes understand what you're trying
to do
and can make it better but not throw it
out and like if they say put a bank
robbery in it when it's you know a love
story or something it's like
what you know and that happens a lot so
i that's one reason why i'm not that big
a fan of writing groups unless it's
professional writers because you can
just writers groups that's why for
instance my round table is not a
writer's group because i don't want
people giving each other notes and
tearing each other apart and falling
into cat fights and gunfire and whatever
you know it's like no it's like you know
professional writers generally will know
if something's working or not they'll
just be able to say well okay here's
this
another thing that's fun is even in
drama
it's good to have comedy humor jokes but
not at the expense of character or plot
so if you for instance if you look at
aliens bill paxton is the one who's
given all the jokes basically but
and they all land but that's because
that's a part of his personality it
doesn't take away from the fact they're
afraid that there's monsters coming
after him that is never
he's never laughing at that
he's nervous and his coping mechanisms
make jokes
and so that's and he's great bill
paxton's just great in that movie you
know so but uh
but yeah i mean
a lot of people
make mistakes
you just have to be willing to grow and
to learn
you just have to be willing to hear
people but not be slavish to them
you have to
decide that no matter what you're not
going to quit
and that doesn't mean you make crap
it means that whatever it takes
you're going to learn
what you need to learn you're going to
partner with who you need to partner
with
and no matter what the world does you're
going to get to the finish line
that's all it is
if you take responsibility and if you
take power and if you decide that the
one person who will be responsible for
your success is you
then
then then you can't be stopped there's
no way to stop you it's a it's you're on
your path
um
and it's great it's a great thing to
wake up with the knowledge that you're
going to create something wonderful
and the world will see it
and
you're not a puppet dancing to someone
else's strings you know you're not
you're not uh
you're not enthralled to anyone other
than your creative vision
you know it's it's it's a it's a great
feeling you know i think uh
the fact that i mean i came out of the
subway in london the tube uh before the
pandemic
and i was going to a pitch meeting with
the bbc elaine and i and someone on the
street said space command mr sci-fi
great that's so great and i was walking
my dogs recently and there was this
russian family we live in a russian
neighborhood russian family
walking across the street sort of
laterally these these
refrigerator-shaped people and the man
saw me with my dogs he said mr sci-fi i
love your commentaries particularly star
trek discovery thank you
i mean it's wonderful i mean how could
you not love that life you know it's
it's great so yeah so it's um
the one thing that makes it all
worthwhile
is that when you do it right when you've
written a script and it's gotten made
and it's gone out to the world and what
you wanted to say is what you said and
people really valued it
it stands the test of time
it lasts decade after decade maybe
hundreds of years
and
it's
you know that you've done something
worth doing
it's it's a great feeling
you know um
you're not you're not just kind of
punching a time clock
and the lovely part is
that you can work a day job and still do
your art
or you can make a living from your art
either path is is honorable
and either path gets your gets your work
out to the world and that's what really
matters
you